the new iPhone 15 lineup has been
released and it's both super similar to
last year's lineup with the regular 15
15 plus 15 Pro and 15 Pro Max models but
it's also very different when you start
getting under the hood making it more
difficult than last year to choose the
right iPhone model to buy so in this
video I'm gonna go through 10 purchasing
mistakes that you need to avoid in order
to make the right choice and then I'm
actually going to give you some real
practical advice on which one to buy
depending on what you really care about
so let's jump right into the first
mistake you need to avoid which is
thinking you need to buy the 15 Pro
Models to get the awesome new smooth
chassis design all of the 15 models come
with the new curved edges that merge the
display into the frame and even better
they now finally have a textured matte
finish on the glass so the regular
models won't be fingerprint magnets
anymore like they have for years these
changes alone will make the regular 15
models feel amazing in the hands just
like the 15 Pro Models moving on to
mistake number two don't think you need
to buy the 15 Pro Models to get the best
display quality this year the regular
iPhone 15s now finally have this same
super Retina xdr Display as you get on
the pros with up to 2 000 nits Peak
outdoor brightness and 1600 nits for HDR
content they also finally get rid of the
notch so they now get the cool Dynamic
Island feature that we got on last
year's 14 Pro Models however beware of
mistake number three because the regular
15s are still lacking a couple of
important features don't think you're
getting identical Dynamic Island and
display experiences because the regular
iPhone 15 models still come with 60
hertz refresh rate displays which means
the dynamic Island animations won't look
nearly as smooth as on the pros as well
as general browsing and swiping through
your tick tocks the regular 15 also
misses out on the always-on display
feature which really made the new iPhone
14 pro model stand out since the display
never turns off so if those features are
important to you don't make the mistake
of buying the regular 15s now for
mistake number four don't assume that
the 15 Pro Models have a much better
camera than the regular ones like what
happened last year because of the 15 and
15 plus now finally get the upgraded 48
megapixel camera sensor from the 14 pro
and even better the aperture is actually
better on the new regular 15s sitting at
F 1.6 compared to F 1.8 on the Pro
Models which means that more light will
come into the sensor for better low
light photography on top of that the
regular 15 models also support the new
24 megapixel photo output which will
give you really sharp photos compared to
what we have now on the 14 pro so don't
think you have to get the 15 Pro Models
moving on to mistake number five don't
assume that the new USBC port on the
iPhone 15 lineup is basically the same
across each model because the one on the
regular 15s is actually very slow with
USB 2.0 speeds which is actually the
same slow speed as the old lightning
Port only the new 15 Pro Models actually
support USB 3.0 with up to 10 gigabits
per second transfer speeds which is a
huge upgrade compared to previous
iPhones so don't make that mistake and
moving on to number six don't assume
that the new a17 Pro chip and the 15 pro
and pro Max is going to be a huge
upgrade in performance compared to the
regular 15s because it still has the
same six core CPU with only a 10 Single
core performance boost and on top of
that the new a17 Pro GP EU only has a 20
Improvement which actually comes from an
additional GPU core with six instead of
five which by itself is twenty percent
more cores so the performance jump is
quite lacking so basically in terms of
performance I think the a16 within the
iPhone 15 will be just fine now getting
into mistake number seven you probably
heard that Apple has officially gotten
rid of leather and replaced it with
their new fine woven case which honestly
looks a bit cheap and not that
protective so regardless of which iPhone
model you buy you're going to want to
get an actual protective case especially
if you choose the expensive pro Max so
this is the u-pro ostan case from our
sponsor Taurus it's slim sleek and
minimalist while looking premium and
feeling super smooth in your hands while
also having military grade drop
protection thanks to its 360 degree the
all-around ax shock airbags absorbing
and dispersing impacts while protecting
the display as well but my favorite part
is the adjustable three-way kickstand
that's actually built into the new 2nd
gen maxafe ring that aligns perfectly to
your max save charger or other
accessories with full support and of
course the Maxa Frank is on a hinge so
you could use it as a stand in any angle
you'd like like portrait and landscape
mode which is great for watching movies
and you can also use it as a finger grip
which is awesome for the 15 Pro Max
they've got great customer support if
you have any questions or concerns and
you can order one today using the link
in the video description and pinned
comment below getting into mistake
number eight if you're someone who hates
heavy phones you no longer have to avoid
the Pro Models because this year the 15
pro and pro Max now come with a new
titanium chassis that makes them 10
lighter than the previous models so now
the 15 Pro is only a bit heavier than
the regular 15 even though it packs a
bunch of extra Hardware so don't make
the mistake of feeling forced to get the
regular models if you don't like heavy
phones for mistake number nine don't
assume that both the 15 pro and pro Max
have the same cameras because they don't
the pro Max now comes with a new 5x
telephoto zoom camera for the first time
ever enabling much better quality Zoom
shots and up to 25 times Zoom length now
this will make it a lot better for
photos and video recording however the
downside to this is that it no longer
has a 3X telephoto camera like the pro
model does so if you're taking photos at
between 3x to 4.9 x Zoom the quality
will actually be better on the less
expensive 15 pro model and finally for
mistake number 10 you probably heard
that the 15 Pro Max mile just got the
first price increase in years being the
only new iPhone 15 model to get more
expensive but don't make the mistake of
choosing the 15 Pro instead because if
you look closely it actually didn't get
more expensive than the 14 pro Max Apple
simply took the 128 gig model away and
now it gets 256 gigs of storage standard
for 11.99 the same price as the 14 pro
Max with the 256 gig upgrade so in
reality you're still getting the same
value as last year but you're being
forced to upgrade the storage this time
around and as a little bonus mistake
don't forget that the new action button
only comes on the Pro Models so don't
make the mistake of getting the regular
15 if you really want that new feature
and now let's finally get into the
buyer's guide portion of this video
starting off with who should be buying
the regular iPhone 15 model of course
it's for those who are are on a budget
looking to upgrade their iPhone for the
least expensive price since it's 7.99 or
only 33 bucks a month and because of
that it's likely also a good first
iPhone for Android users who are finally
deciding to switch over since many
Android phones start at a lower base
price and this year the regular 15
models arguably got the biggest upgrades
with a dynamic Island and super Retina
xdr display that matches the Pro Models
as well as the same new curved design
and matte back glass USBC and the new 48
megapixel camera so in terms of value
you can't beat the regular iPhone 15.
now of course the 15 plus is meant for
those who really want a larger display
but aren't willing to dish out the crazy
1200 for the pro Max model this is
honestly a really good middle ground
especially since the display is so nice
now on the regular 15 plus now the 6.1
inch iPhone 15 pro model is for those
who want the best of the best features
like the 120 hertz Pro motion feature
always on display 3x telephoto camera
new titanium chassis and super fast USBC
Port as well as the new a17 Pro chip and
this one is still available at the same
999 dollar price which is insane in the
face of inflation so it's a really great
choice for anyone who wants it all
especially in this smaller size and with
the new fun action button and finally
the 15 Pro Max is for those who want the
best features with the largest display
and the best battery life basically the
king of all iPhones and as a bonus the
larger display is going to make the
pill-shaped cutout look smaller as well
as the actual bezel size which is super
thin this year so it's going to give you
the Ultimate Experience for consuming
media playing video games or anything
else you can do on your iPhone and as an
added bonus you now get the new 5x
telephoto camera which will greatly
improve far range Zoom shots so there
you guys go if you're going to be
upgrading to a new iPhone 15 let me know
which model you're getting down below as
well as the iPhone you currently have
right now and definitely click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one thanks to Taurus
for sponsoring this video as well as you
for watching and I'll see you in the
next video
foreign
[Music]